Hey, whats up guys?
We are back outside and today is the day we're testing these homemade, pull tab, pyrotechnics.
the idea here really is convenience, rather than having to light a fuse with a barbecue igniter
we want to be able to pull these tabs and have our pyrotechnics light themselves.
So lets dive right in and see if they actually work!
Now to kick things off, I'm going to get started with one of these small paper tubes that we made.
This is the smallest and one of the cleanest ones that I've made
So it should give us the safest results.
Moment of truth guys! Lets go light it off!
Theoretically i should just be able to pull this and the thing will light itself, lets see if that's really the case!
Haha! The handle broke, i need more friction!
Oh dude! The fuse came out!
What the heck!
*Laughter*
Oh its still going to work though!
There it goes!
Nice! Nice!
I love the smell of smoke bomb in the morning!
So that was a success and it wasn't nearly as dangerous of a burn as i thought it was going to be.
So for this one, I think i'm going to try pulling the tab and throwing it more smoke grenade style!
That was cool! Did you hear the way that it popped when it went off?
It was like "BANG!"
It went off in the wrong direction though, it kind of shot of to the side and i wanted it more pointed inwards.
So i'm going to grab another one and we're going to try that again.
There it goes.
I really want that thing to go upright though
woah!
Look at the smoke! Look over by the slide! Look up into the trees! That's a lot of smoke!
Yep! Not going to complain about that, that's awesome!
Lets check out the damage!
Our pyrotechnic compositions melted off the hot glue, they just fall off the cardboard bases.
But surprisingly, the cardboard bases didn't ignite on fire, they're just charred.
These pieces of paper have crumbled into ash.
That's 100% success, lets go bigger!
I'm not exactly sure how we are going to do it, but for this next one, id like to see two go off at once!
Cool! Here we go!
Sweet!
Oh! The other one hasn't taken off!
C'mon! You can do it!
Oh there it goes
Oh that's a fair amount of smoke!
Wow! Look over here! Look over by the trees and the pond!
That house is just completely covered in a smoke screen, that's awesome!
Wow!
Cool! That was awesome!
For this next experiment, let's try taking one of these big ones, burying it in the sandpit and see how these things do underground.
Will it even light off? We're about to find out
Moment of truth!
Woah!
That's kind of cool!
It's still burning underground, look at that!
It's like spewing ash! Kind of looks like a volcano!
Look at that! All that smoke rising up out of the sand! With a little geyser coming out from the top
Oh thats really hot! As you'd expect it would be, right?
Look at that! Oh my gosh that is freakin' cool!
Wow! This is way to much fun!
Okay, that exceeded my expectations.
So apparently smoke bombs will go off underground, who knew?
We're down to our last two pyrotechnics, and i saved the best for last.
We've got this refurbished smoke grenade and a cup full of the left overs, lets go with the grenade first!
I think for this one i'm going to get a little bit gutsy and see if i can hold on to the container while it actually smokes and goes off
This burns a lot hotter and a lot more vigorously than the normal smoke composition that would be in here.
Because we're using a potassium nitrate, but that's why i am wearing gloves, safety first!
I'm looking forward to this one!
Here we go!
Oh wow! That works better than i thought!
Phew! It's raining hot ash on me but it's working, look it's working really well!
That is a lot of smoke!
And its not even hot on the outside, I can hold it bare handed and it feels just fine.
This blows me away, i was expecting flames to be shooting out of there, but the flames seem to be tempered, and it was just a lot of really good smoke
I do feel the heat starting to be transfer down to the plastic now, but for the most part
That was an epic success! I'm really proud of that guys! That worked really, really well!
For the Grand finale, lets bring out Big Bertha!
This one here guys, I'm really looking forward to, that is a lot of material and i think its going to get really hot, really fast!
So we're going to do it close to water.
Now if you look in the centre here, you can see that as the composition cooled, it actually sucked down quite a bit into the centre
So I'm not sure how well that fuse is going to stay on
I'm hoping that there is still enough friction in there to hold the fuse and the igniter in place as we pull it, so lets go find out!
Not going to lie, I am a little bit nervous about this one, but we just got to suck it up!
Here we go!
Oh yea, there's plenty of delay time there.
Oh, there it goes!
The flames are shooting at least two feet tall! And look at all that smoke!
Oh my heck! That was a lot of smoke!
I wouldn't be surprised if the neighbours complain on that one!
Lets take a look at the glass
Oh my goodness! Look at the top here!
This is where the rim used to be.
I'm actually really surprised that that's stayed intact as much as it did
But you can see the top has just fell off
I thought for sure this glass would have been completely disintegrated.
That was a pretty good size fireball guys! And honestly i cant think off any better way to deal with leftovers, then to light them of in style!
So guys, lets recap what just happened.
We started off with our smallest and cleanest smoke bomb because we weren't sure they'd even work at all, but they did work.
So we tossed them hand grenade style and watched them go off and that was fun.
Then we moved it up to lighting off two off them at the same time.
That was so much fun that we moved over to the sandpit to see if our smoke bombs could still burn underneath the sand, and they did.
And actually that right there was probably the most surprising thing of this whole experiment here today.
We lit one of our smoke bombs off inside off a plastic grenade and that was a tremendous success
And we took all the left over scraps, put them in a cup and lit them off by my fishpond.
A day like this cant get any better unless you have a little bit of pyrotechnics and a whole lot of smoke.
Thanks for joining me for this experiment guys, I'l be looking for you in the next one
Talk to you then!
Oh! It just came right out, haha, need a better way to hold that!